Is
a conventional wisdom kind of idea?
This is like the greatest period of
technological change in history
and certainly by some measures,
there have been immense changes that are
hard to imagine.
Uh,
uh,
having been matched in the past,
as we said earlier in this interview,
I don't know that there's been a period
of time when people have so rapidly
gained access to so much information.
But there've been other big eras where
technology change very fast to beginning
of the last century when the automobile,
the airplane,
the Telegraph,
all these things came along very
quickly.
The telephone,
uh,
even further back in history,
various developments in medicine and
sanitation and other things that really
had huge outcomes in the way people
lived and worked.
And what gets me up every morning is
that I,
I am living in one of those periods.
Even if it's not,
it doesn't matter to me that it's the
biggest or the fastest or whatever.
It's one of those periods of amazing
technological change.
I,
I work for a publication that is
respected and that has resources for me
to cover these changes.
And I get to,
uh,
see a lot of these things,
not only early but in the context of how
they were developed.
The developers come,
uh,
they want me to write about it.
And so we have a conversation about why
didn't you do this?
How did you come to doing this?
What was your idea?
They love talking about it.
I love listening to it.
It also gives me a chance to meet a
important I people I think are important
historical figures the way that I used
to when I covered.
And I used to go to the White House
sites to go to the Kremlin.
I used to go to all these places,
10 Downing Street,
these various places.
Uh,
now I go to Google,
I go to Microsoft,
I go to apple.
I,
uh,
have spent many hours of conversation
over the years,
uh,
with people like Bill Gates and Steve
Jobs and the guys who founded Google and
uh,
Steve case who founded AOL and numerous
other people.
And so,
um,
I've learned a lot from that and I feel
like it must have been,
like,
it would've been like if you had sort of
modern journalism covering Henry Ford or
Thomas Edison or whatever.
So that gets me up in the morning.
It's fascinating.